[Music]
hello welcome everybody thanks for
coming out
my name is John Shriver Blake and I'm a
product manager for firebase and I'll be
joined later today by Mike McDonald
who's also a firebase product manager
and we are here today to talk about
building enterprise-grade mobile apps
with firebase you see lots of people
know that firebase is a great way to
build great apps and that helps you
throughout the lifecycle of your app
development process it can help you
build your app with functions sorry with
features like firestore cloud storage
and authentication you can store and
sync data in the cloud for your mobile
app without running your own back-end
services you can then build on top of
that functionality using cloud functions
to run back-end code once again without
your own servers finally you can use
firebase to help you take advantage of
ml in your app using ml kit and both
client and cloud side api's beyond
building your app firebase can help you
with your app quality you can use
crashlytics to get a real-time feed of
your crashes as they have happen in wild
you can then use crashlytics to
prioritize and help fix those issues you
can also get a clear idea of your apps
performance and how it's being perceived
by your users and improve upon your
performance with firebase performance
monitoring finally you can run tests for
your app on devices managed by Google
with firebase test lab beyond quality we
can help you grow your app this starts
with Google Analytics for firebase which
gives you free and unlimited app
analytics so you can have a clear
understanding of what your users are
doing in your app once you have that
understanding you can then optimize that
experience using a/b testing firebase
cloud messaging and remote config to
really get your users more engaged and
using more of your app finally we have
predictions which uses ml to to analyze
your users behavior and creates custom
groups so then you can then target those
users for instance there's a custom
group for
retention that'll give you an idea of
users who are likely to churn you can
then use notifications or a/b testing or
remote config just to create specific
experiences from the for those users to
keep them from churning out of your app
there really is a lot that firebase has
to offer the problem is many people
think that firebase can't be used in an
enterprise setting and so I get
questions all the time about security
compliance privacy and production
readiness for firebase and so today
we're going to answer some of those
questions and give you the information
that you need to get firebase deployed
in your organization specifically we're
going to cover these three areas is
firebase ready for your organization can
you manage your resources in firebase
and control access in the way that you
need to is firebase ready for your
lawyers will it meet your regulatory and
compliance requirements and finally is
firebase ready for production will it
scale can you monitor it in the way that
you expect so first let's talk about
your organization can you manage and
control access to firebase projects in
the way that you need to the answer is
yes
firebase users can use Google clouds
enterprise-grade tools to manage and
control access to firebase resources
which is great right and this is
possible because when it comes right
down to it
firebase projects are cloud projects now
we in the firebase team have often built
tools to help users get onto the
firebase platform in an easy and simple
way but underlying all of it is Google
cloud platform and so users who want to
can take advantage of more powerful
Google cloud platform tools to perform
more advanced administrative scenarios
let's talk about some of the tools that
cloud makes available for this type of
management the first is Google cloud
resource manager this is your central
way to manage cloud and firebase
resources within your organization
it gives administrators the ability to
view all of the projects and resources
deployed in their org to organize those
projects in a hierarchy with folders and
then assign access
at the org folder project and resource
level ii is cloud identity this is your
centralized identity management solution
for cloud it allows you to manage users
and groups and supports products like
single sign-on and two-factor
authentication so you can be sure that
your users are having both a safe and
secure user experience
finally is cloud I am which is identity
and access management this gives you
fine-grained access control of who has
access to what in your organization you
do this by assigning roles to specific
users and groups that give them limited
access within cloud for instance there's
a role called app engine viewer which
gives users the ability to view app
engine configuration this is a fairly
broad role so you might assign it fairly
broadly let's say to a group on the
other hand you might reserve at more of
an edit role to a smaller set of people
cloud iam puts you in that level of
control now those are predefined roles
something a cloud I am also supports our
custom roles and so if you find that the
predefined roles define that we've
defined are not sufficient for your
needs you can get really granular and
create roles with exactly the
permissions that you need for your
organization finally I want to mention
that all changes to iam are audited and
logged in a trapeze so that you can go
back and get a clearer view of what
changes were made when and by whom in
your project now those of you are
familiar firebase probably know that
today we don't offer a lot of options
for fine-grained access control with
firebase
well good news rolling out now is fine
great access control for firebase this
is actually available to some of you
today and will be broadly available by
the end of the summer we've defined a
set of predefined roles for firebase
users like quality admin or developer
viewer that allow you to very easily
give people in firebase access to a
limited subset of the functionality in
addition will be supporting custom roles
so you can create your own roles with
exactly the permissions that make the
most sense for your organization now
this is all rolling out now but I'm
gonna give you a preview of what will
look like
so you've got a good idea okay
so here I am in the firebase console you
can see I'm logged in as me and I want
to go ahead and give Mike access to my
project so that he can send
notifications so I'm going to go into
settings and this brings up a firebase
specific user management UI I'm gonna go
ahead and add Mike there we go and I'm
gonna select a role and you can see in
the role drop-down there's the project
level roles that firebase has always
supported but I can also give my custom
access to firebase and you know somebody
who's gonna wear shorts to a
presentation I'm not so sure I trust
their professionalism so I'm gonna lock
down like as much as possible by giving
him only grow admin access which means
he can access notifications but can't
access for instance the contents of my
database so there we go
I'm gonna add Mike cool so let me switch
over to Mike you can see her I am logged
in as firebase Mike and because mike has
Gro admin access if I go to cloud
messaging you can see he has full
read/write access but if I go to
database access tonight he needs to ask
a project owner for the necessary
permissions so I've been able to grant
access Mike to only the things that he
needs and I don't have to worry about
him accessing things that he shouldn't
be now some of you may be thinking that
these are a little too coarse-grained
for you and for those folks you can use
custom roles so switching back to me
once again logged in as me I'm gonna go
ahead and show you how you do a custom
role now this is not something that we
support in our UI because it's more of
an advanced user scenario so I'm gonna
go ahead and click advanced permissions
what this does is open up the full
Google cloud platform console and the
full iam experience there and if I go
into the flyout here you can see that
there's really a lot of additional
functionality that's available here for
folks who want to take advantage of it
one of those things are roles so as I
load this up you'll see there's a long
list of the predefined roles but in
addition to those roles I've created a
special role just for Mike
that gives them exactly the access
that he needs and nothing else so
there's really a lot of flexibility here
for those who need it finally I
mentioned audit logging so I'm going to
quickly move over to the Google cloud
platform Activity Stream which is a
central place to see all of the
administrative actions that have
happened in your organization including
I am and it's a little slow
it's the Wi-Fi I'm going to blame the
Wi-Fi here we go and there it is so not
only do I have a full activity view of
all of the changes that have happened to
my organization it also reflects the
change that I just made
firebase John assigned firebase growth
admin to firebase Mike so I can get that
full view of all the changes happening
in my org which is super important to me
as a project administrator so going back
to the deck
the key takeaway for you for this
section is that you can use the same
powerful tools available in Google cloud
platform to manage and control access to
your firebase resources okay so let's
talk about our lawyers anybody who've
ever deployed a new service in a large
organization knows that it can be a real
challenge particularly because of the
lawyers if a service doesn't meet your
compliance and regulatory needs it can
be a complete non-starter
in addition gdpr and other emergent
privacy regulations have a-- they this
this much more complicated we in
firebase want to make this easier for
you and we've been doing a lot of work
to that end and we're happy to say that
today firebase is ready to meet most
organizations compliance needs including
helping you achieve EPR now before I get
too much further I want to make this
really clear I am NOT a lawyer and this
is not legal advice if you haven't
discussed some of these topics with a
lawyer yet I strongly suggest that you
do gdpr so I'd a interesting experience
this past winter I was at a water park
with my son and we were waiting in this
very long line to get into the water
park and all of a sudden a couple behind
me who
all so much to work together started
talking about gdpr and i could not
understand why they were talking about
GPRO to water park and they were really
stressing out about it they were going
on and on about how much work they had
to do how many open questions they had
and how hard it was to get a straight
answer and it was only later that I
realized I was wearing this t-shirt says
gdpr turns out that my gdpr t-shirt
ruined that couples vacation I felt bad
about that I worked on gdpr for fire
base and I could relate it was a lot of
work and a fair amount of stress but
with the benefit of hindsight I've come
to view it as an opportunity it's an
opportunity to make sure that you're
doing the right thing for your users and
their privacy so we're going to talk
about today is how to implement best
practices for privacy and how firebase
can help you do that
we're going to cover these three
specific areas that I think many app
developers have challenges with and are
particularly important today one are the
services that you're using protecting
your users data properly - do you have
proper consent flows for your users and
three are you giving users transparency
control that they need let's talk about
the first one it's almost impossible
these days to build an app without
relying on third-party services many of
you are probably using firebase Google
cloud platform and any number of other
services in your app if those services
have access to user data it's really
important that you have a clear
understanding of what data those
services are capturing how that data is
protected and how it's used by those
services and it's on you it's the app
developer to ensure that all of that is
compliant with your privacy policy
Terms of Service and consent experience
how can firebase help with this well
first in order to help you be more
confident in firebase is privacy and
security practices we've been working
hard to get industry standard
certifications for firebase you can see
that we already have a bevy of ISO and
Sox certifications for many firebase
products and we're continuing to expand
this constant
you can see just recently we added ISO
27-17 and ISO 27:18 for firestore and
you'll see more of these over the coming
weeks months and years in addition to
third-party certifications something new
with gdpr is the concept of a DPS tee
what a DPS tee is is a legal agreement
between you and your service provider
that governs how they are protecting and
using your user data if you're subject
to gdpr is very important that you have
these in place with all of your service
providers the good news is that firebase
makes this really easy all firebase
services are covered under a GP st and
that DP st is included by default in our
Terms of Service so if we're using our
products and you've accepted our most
recent terms you're covered under our
DPS tees okay consent flows I want to
highlight consent flows because the
standards for consent flows are changing
its consent flow that was totally fine a
year or two ago may not be fine under
current norms and so if you haven't
reviewed your flows recently I strongly
suggest that you do the overall goal
here is to make it really clear your
users what data you're collecting about
them and how you're gonna use it and
getting really clear consent for that
use from your users there's been a lot
of back and forth about check boxes
versus buttons the main takeaway here is
that you want to get really really clear
consent from folks now once you have
that experience right you're not quite
done yet there's a few other things that
tend to trip up developers one is you
need to be really careful about what
data you're collecting before you have
consent from your users we see this all
too often where people accidentally
collect data that they shouldn't be when
their app starts for instance be very
careful that you're not doing on - you
need to make sure that you're recording
consent in a way that you can prove it
so if a regulator comes to you down the
road and says do you have consent for
user X you should be able to prove that
on your back-end so how can firebase
help first firebase has done a lot of
work to true
your control over how data is collected
and when we have a number of services
like crashlytics and analytics for
instance that by default wake up when
the app wakes up and starts collecting
data in some cases that's totally fine
in other cases you may decide that you
want to get consent before that data is
collected so it's now possible with all
firebase services that have this
behavior to change their default
behavior so you can configure them not
to load on start and activate them for
programmatically when you have consent
and you're ready to gather the data in
addition we published some example code
for notice and consent this includes UI
for how to get consent but also how to
store consent with firebase in a way
that gives you the tracking that you
need this is available today in our
friendly pics app and for those of you
aren't familiar with friendly pics it's
an open source app for Android iOS and
web that shows you actually a bunch of
things about how to build on firebase
and so I strongly suggest that you take
a look at that to get a better idea of
how to get this critical experience
right alright finally are you offering
users transparency and control of their
data the key goal here is that your
users should have clear visibility into
what data you have about them and that
they should be in control of that data
I've put up a screenshot here from the
Google my activity center which i think
is a really good example of how to do
transparency control well this is
available to all Google users and when
you log in it gives you a detailed view
of your usage of Chrome search Android
and a bunch of other developer tools
it's really quite exhaustive you can see
it includes individual searches that
I've run on Google in addition to giving
me a lot of transparency it also puts me
in control I can delete individual
records I can delete data in bulk I can
even export data for use outside of
Google services I think this is a really
good example of what we all should be
doing to provide our users more
transparency at control so how does
transparency how does firebase help with
this first we've looked through all of
our applications on all of our services
to make sure that they have really good
delete support so that for instance if
you get a request
delete a specific users data you can go
through and delete crashlytics data or
analytics data associated with those
users some of our services didn't have
the best support there and that's all
been updated recently to ensure that you
can be in compliant which compliance
with GD P R in addition we published an
export and deletion guide that
demonstrates how to properly handle user
deletion and user export for apps built
on firebase it's actually really quite
powerful and simple using the power of
cloud functions so I'm gonna walk you
through a little bit of how that works
before I do I want to mention that this
is all up on github in the firebase
repository under user privacy it's open
source so you can grab it today and
start using it in your apps ok so I
mentioned we're gonna use cloud
functions in order to do this stuff and
what's great about cloud functions is
the flexibility you have in terms of
when functions are kicked off in this
case we're gonna take advantage of the
fact that firebase authentication is an
event emitter and so you can see at the
top of this code we're keying off of
functions auth user dot on delete what
this means is that when a firebase off
user gets deleted this function will get
called and then clean up the rest of the
data now this is really very flexible
you could also rely on an HTTP request
to kick this off you can even use our
client-side SDK to kick off this
function once it's initiated this
function basically just goes through and
calls wipe out calls for each one of our
services in firebase so let's go ahead
and look at the database playback call
once again fairly simple function what
this does is it loads in a number of
paths from a config and then iterates
through those paths deleting each one of
them from the database but how does
where does the paths come from well
they're over here and user privacy JSON
you can see here I've specified two
paths users and admins both in this case
keyed off of the user ID so I can know
that when my auth user gets deleted the
data at these two paths will also get to
leave them this also works for other
services and I've included an example of
how this was
work in storage further down so there it
is with a few simple functions I can
rest assured that when my firebase off
user gets deleted their data is out of
my system as well so the key takeaway
for you is that firebase has done a lot
of work to make sure that we can meet
the compliance and regulatory needs of
most organizations and that we've done a
lot of work to help you be compliant
with gdpr
and with that I'm gonna hand it over to
Mike who's going to talk about taking
your firebase app to production thanks
John okay
so John just showed functions code that
needs to get deployed somewhere
he showed databases and storage buckets
how do we know that that code is
actually gonna scale once it's out in
production and once it's out there how
do we know that John didn't just copy
those blindly from a github repo and
deploy them and assume that they work
right we need to verify that our
functions aren't crashing that code is
actually running and doing what we think
it will and lastly we have to make sure
that we're not breaking the bank right
we don't want someone from finance
crawling up into our cubicle and saying
you're spending way too much money you
need to shut that down because that's a
critical part of your business
so let's tackle those individually
because firebase is built on top of
cloud it can both scale to meet those
incredible needs of your organization
but with tools like functions and server
lists we're also making sure that we can
do it economically so we'll start with
scale a lot of firebase features like
cloud firestore cloud storage and cloud
functions as the name implies are built
on top of Google cloud so you can use
the firebase client SDKs and are really
really nice console to maximize
developer productivity and then if you
need to do things like automate the
creation of storage buckets or create
different environments for all of your
functions you can also use the power of
the various tools that Google cloud
provides in order to kind of supercharge
and provide that the granular
customizability that you need one of the
other things because of that is that a
lot of firebase services like those are
available in other regions so
cloud storage for instance you can
create buckets in all of these regions
and actually it's probably out of date
because I'm I bet we'd probably just
launched new regions today or sometime
in the in the recent past we have a ton
of different regions so you can meet
either compliance needs or performance
needs right if you have users in
Australia for instance you might want to
have buckets in Australia to meet either
you know the Australian data locality
requirements or just simple performance
along that lines today or in the in the
recent past or in the recent few or near
future
cloud functions will be offering reason
ality support so you can actually take
your functions and deploy them exactly
where your users are you can just type
in you know - - region and deploy to
whatever region this will be coming for
cloud firestore as well in the future
okay so we've deployed all of our
various resources how do we know that
those resources are actually doing what
we say they're doing so that's where a
stack driver comes in
so stack driver is not only Google's
monitoring solution but it will also do
alerting
it will do error reporting basically
it's kind of the one-stop shop for your
operational needs firebase has a number
of integrations with stackdriver so you
can take a look at the various cloud
integrated services and see which pieces
of stackdriver
are currently included so a ton of
things kick out metrics to stack driver
monitoring and therefore you can alert
based on changes to those and then cloud
functions provides really nice logging
and error reporting that I'll demo later
so well actually we'll show it right now
and then we'll demo in a minute but John
went and deployed a bunch of functions
friendly picks I think actually has
about 15 different functions running in
the background for everything from you
know cleaning up user accounts after
they've been deleted - right it's a
pictures on the internet app so what is
what are people gonna post on the
Internet horrible horrible you know
ridiculous content so we actually have a
function that runs the cloud vision API
and it will pull in the photo do a NSFW
or inappropriate content filtering on it
and then decide whether or not to modern
it and again that's a business critical
thing so you know look up here make sure
that nothing is erroring out and on the
case that something is erroring out we
can actually dive into stackdriver
error reporting and take a look at
exactly what error is occurring so you
know if you if you notice here we can
see things like permission denied you
know I couldn't write to the database
because something happened or you could
actually see if you look at mine that I
don't know how to program JavaScript and
so I get a bunch of crazy JavaScript
errors that are basically just like hey
Mike doesn't know how to program but you
can start doing things like opening or
closing those or acknowledging them that
someone is working on it and kind of
track that so we'll demo that right at
the end okay
so we've kind of verified logs are
looking good we're getting you know
hopefully no errors showing up an error
reporting now we want longer-term
monitoring so we want to make sure that
you know the cloud is up and still
responding but we also may want to know
things like how much data is being added
to our storage bucket right so how many
pictures are being added per day I want
to know because you know Finance has
told me that I can only spend $100 a
month on this app I want to start
sending yeah you know making sure that
I'm not storing more than 100 gigabytes
of data I can use stackdriver monitoring
to start setting alerts and
understanding you know maybe put up a
big dashboard for the entire team to see
what growth looks like and start setting
alerts based on that a bunch of
different firebase products offer a ton
a ton of ton of different metrics on
this and as I mentioned you can then
through stackdriver
start dashboarding these things so this
is a dashboard that I built for friendly
picks that has data stored so I set a 5
gigabyte alert so 5 gigabytes I think is
the free tier limit for storage so I
said hey I want to draw a line across
that and make sure that I'm not getting
close and then set up an alert based on
that similarly I want to track other key
you know key metrics like bandwidth or
requests coming in to the database in
storage and as I said I can then set up
policies based on those metrics so this
is my alert for five gigabytes so you
can see let me know anytime the total
bytes metric is above five gigabytes
for more than one minute and I will send
that email to firebase Mike though I
could if I wanted to and I actually have
services running that send me really
annoying text messages if my minecraft
server goes down just to make sure that
everything is up and running and these
these alerts are actually great because
you can add markdown documentation so
you know for instance maybe you already
have a playbook for your service you can
actually drop that playbook
documentation directly into it so
whenever I get an email where my
minecraft server goes down it actually
has exactly the three steps that I
usually just have to copy and paste
because I haven't automated it directly
into you know SSH into the machine fix
it and I'm done right so you get
everything there and then you get
another email saying hey you know we've
cleaned up the issue everything is good
to go again and this is actually an
exact example of that right where you
see hey minecraft server is failing
right down to the bottom we have the
policy documentation that is literally
just hey make sure the VM is still
running mount whatever appropriate disks
etc etc and then when it's fixed you can
see hey the violation is ended
everything is all clear the last thing
we talked about all of those finance
people cropping up in unexpected times
right when your service is on its
stellar growth you need to make sure
that one you can estimate the cost of
your service so we've provided cost
calculators through both firebase and
Google cloud to understand hey you know
maybe you're building a chat app and you
want to send a certain number of
messages or you're storing a certain
number of pictures we can let you kind
of slide around and see approximately
what it's gonna cost to run on our
infrastructure and because you want to
ensure that once your thing is running
you're not gonna just completely blow
your budget away you can actually start
setting budget alerts so I set a budget
alert here that I don't want to spend
any more than $50 a month running my
minecraft server so I set at 50 percent
send me an alert at 90% and 100% send me
an email that just says hey Mike
fYI you know you're coming up on your
budget alert and one of the things John
and I were actually talking right before
this talk we've kind of created this fun
recursive system where you can actually
have billing alerts trigger functions
that would then let you say shut off
resources which is kind of fun because
those functions also cost money and you
know would end up in this weird world
where who knows what you could end up
doing but that's kind of the system that
we're trying to build right we're giving
you all of the tools and then in
firebase we're working to kind of
automate that and orchestrate it to give
you you know really the control you need
at a at a high level so let's switch
over the demo and I will actually show
you by building a couple of things how
this all works so here we're looking at
the the back end for friendly picks and
hopefully everyone can see that in the
back of the room but you can see a bunch
of logs that we have and you can start
seeing things like oh we're getting some
warning so maybe I want to actually dive
into that and we can just search for
warning and I can say load more logs low
load older logs scroll through etc and
they're actually a ton of things that
give out logs so I can for instance look
at various audited resources and say hey
you know I want to know everything
calling the vision API or I want to know
all of the changes that have been made
to the Google OAuth client ID and a
bunch of that information also shows up
and if I want I could also dive into say
particulars and maybe I know that one of
these functions is being problematic I
want to look for logs on that not only
can I kind of filter by doing arbitrary
text I could filter by kind of any of
these other columns maybe only give me
you know critical errors in all
functions and hopefully in the last hour
there have not been any critical errors
though well let it load and see if that
if that is actually true if there are I
recommend deleting friendly pics no yeah
there you go so nothing is horribly
broken in friendly pics right now and if
it was so actually we did this talk at
i/o and we were having errors so I
immediately added all sorts of alerting
and now the developers get pinged
whenever anything happens and so clearly
they have have fixed all of the bugs and
friendly pics because of that okay so
speaking of those alert
I'll actually pop open to some that I've
resolved or muted we'll see I thought I
had some more I guess everything is
going well because we only have one so
we can dive in and we can see hey we've
been failing to send notifications we
can actually see the entire stack trace
of you know hey here's the JavaScript
code so you can see where is it
yeah a bunch of server errors whatever a
message targeted to an iOS device could
not be so it's a it's an APNs
certificate issue so now that's kind of
giving us all the things that we need to
then go and fix the problem you can also
see kind of all of the the instances
when this has happened as well as this
will have kind of time correlation so
you can see hey maybe this only started
two days ago is there something that we
did in our infrastructure two days ago
that made this occur and then you know
when you're done you can say hey you
know I've acknowledged that this is the
case you can actually stick in say
you're using github and someone has
filed an issue you can stick in you know
github issue tracking or you know JIRA
or whatever tool you're using and
acknowledge it there so you have this
kind of other tracking built in over the
dashboards so this was the dashboard
that we saw earlier that showed you know
the 5 gigabyte gigabyte storage special
you can see both database and cloud
storage storage as well as you know
bandwidth storage etc so I would
actually add another one I want to start
tracking those function invocations so
we had you know six or seven functions I
want to know which ones are being called
you know is there any correlation
between them maybe if something happens
I want to know if one of those functions
is going haywire so I'll add another
chart and so we'll just call that
functions executions and we'll say cloud
functions and there's an executions
metric that tells us count of cloud
functions executions broken down by
status and so you can actually see we
have a ton of different functions you
know for instance how much memory each
function is using and how many times
they're being invoked I only care about
filtering by the function name right but
I could say oh I want to know functions
in this region and maybe measure their
agency and see if the functions in a
certain region are faster or slower than
functions in another region but for now
we'll just group them by function name
and do the sum right I only care about
the total number of functions being
executed you know potentially across all
regions or you know regardless of status
code but I I may want to say only give
me functions that succeed or only give
me functions that fail so we'll save
that and we can see immediately we get
that new dashboard no that's only for
the past day we could also start doing
historical things so I'd actually
already loaded that so it's pretty quick
but this is the past week of function
executions so I can kind of scroll
through there again we're not seeing
terribly interesting things maybe in the
past month we'll see yeah so you can see
a couple spikes I'm curious around IO or
when we launched this if there were some
more spikes okay
so this would be like a great dashboard
that you could set up for your team and
the last thing would be setting up an
alerting policy so I have a couple
pretty simple alerting policies so I
have one that says you know any time
storage is over five gigabytes but I
also have a couple other more
interesting ones for instance let me
know if the number of objects in my
storage bucket has doubled in the past
12 hours right and that could indicate
you know hey maybe my app really got
popular on the App Store and kind of
gives you this kind of heads-up of maybe
I need to start you know different
financial planning or just you know
maybe our marketing team has done
something that may affect our
infrastructure so I'll create another
alert right we have a simple one for
storage being over over quota I will
copy that and create one for the
database and do a similar thing right I
want to know when let's pull it up and
the resource we'll use when the
real-time database is so we can do and
they really made a mess has a ton of
different metrics but we'll do bytes
stored and the condition if it is above
and we'll do one let's try I think that
should be one gigabyte because it's all
in bytes for more than one minute and we
will save that condition and then as you
can see I could start adding
notifications I can actually send it to
the mobile app I could SMS
myself I could send it to a slack
channel kind of we're trying to meet you
wherever you are as as a team for now
we'll just send it to my email again I
can add some Docs you know I don't
really know what to do here maybe this
is you know send an email to someone to
let them know who knows and we'll call
this database over quota threshold and
we'll save that policy and we'll go back
cool we have that policy and you can see
I have not unfortunately found a great
way to start triggering these because
obviously it takes a little bit and you
know for instance storage isn't
monetized immediately but you'll have to
trust me I get these emails all the time
they're fantastic I will show one other
thing I will pop over to the billing tab
and oh I do too I don't actually know if
I can do that
I'll switch projects and show you a
billing account in a different project
do do I like how it shows it and then
immediately there we go
so I do have a billing account for here
and I will show you billing alerts so go
to the linked billing account so I can
set up a budget that is my $50 a month
spend limit and you can see that trigger
alerts at 50 percent 90 percent and 100
percent and you can see there that I've
used seven dollars and sixty eight cents
out of ten dollars which is I guess that
oh I ramped it down I will actually call
that a $10 a month spending limit link
to a project I can say hey targeted to
last month spend and let me know if I'm
above last month spend which was I guess
ten dollars and sixty cents or I could
enter you know maybe I'm gonna bump it
up and call it fifteen note how it auto
calculates to so I can add just a
percent maybe you know notify me at a
hundred and fifty percent of my budget
just in case I keep going over and as
John mentioned you can connect this up
to a pub subtopic we can get fed into
functions so you could start turning
resources off or to other things so
we'll save it and I bet actually if I if
I set it below I could get an email and
prove it you there but you won't do that
oh other way okay back to the slides
so John talked about firebase being
ready organizationally and kind of from
a legal and compliance standpoint and
then I talked about production ization
scaling monitoring alerting
understanding kind of the finances of
your application so yes at this point we
believe that firebase is ready for the
needs of large organizations there's
still a lot to work on but as we
integrate deeper with Google cloud
platform we'll keep getting more of the
compliance more regionality more awesome
monitoring and scaling and budget
alerting through Google cloud so thank
you everyone for coming
we'll be around after four questions if
you have them otherwise enjoy the rest
of next
[Music]